[Music]  when you showed up in Game of Thrones as  Drago is announcing it quickly yes you  are thank you that that you were such a  forceful male presence that there are a  lot of women that say that your  character improved their sex lives  because they were able to say that's  what I want I want to forceful you know  men are becoming so you know Oh what  would you like I want to make you so  happy and then your character came along  yes the woman here now yeah they're  looking for a little servicemen it's  sort of an agressor TIFF yeah yeah I  mean woman here now me yes I tried it on  my wife it didn't forget yeah road to  Paloma was a film that you made where  you actually had to got to got to have a  love scene with your lovely wife finally  yeah yeah I directed the movie yeah it's  coming out in July and we have there's  definitely a little love scene in there  that's exciting  Mitch I admit that sub-zone creepy that  creepy I can't wait to see  [Laughter]  [Applause]